[Música]
desmond dutu falleció a los 90 años el
arzobispo emérito y premio nobel de paz
es considerado una de las figuras clave
de la lucha contra la opresión racista
del apartheid en sudáfrica su funeral
será el primero de n
hace exactamente un mes la ms designó
como de preocupación a la variante o
micro en el coronavirus se detectaron
los científicos de sudáfrica desde
entonces este linaje se ha convertido en
el predominante en varios países
israel anunció su nuevo plan por 300
millones de dólares para duplicar los
asentamientos judíos en los altos del
golán un territorio cuya soberanía
también es reclamada por siria
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy manejé a la calle y es un gusto
saludarlos y desmontó icono de la lucha
contra la parte del falleció a los 90
años en su natal sudáfrica fue el primer
obispo negro de johannesburgo y luego
arzobispo emérito anglicano de ciudad
del cabo su lucha contra la desigualdad
racial y el régimen del apartheid le
valió en 1984 el premio nobel de paz él
se opuso de manera no violenta a la
minoría blanca sudafricana los líderes
del mundo le rinden un homenaje de
despedida
[Música]
y para entender mejor el legado de
desmon tutú conectamos a esta hora con
jerónimo delgado coordinador de estudios
africanos de la universidad externado de
colombia señor delgado gracias por estar
con nosotros explícanos que significo
desmon tutú para el fin de la partida y
en sudáfrica
de un tufo de los grandes activistas en
contra del régimen de la partida
recordemos que mientras la gran mayoría
de líderes del congreso nacional
africano estuvieran en la cárcel dos
minutos estuvo afuera en las calles
fomentando la resistencia pacífica no
violenta contra el apartheid y participó
activamente todo el proceso primero de
caída del apartheid después de
negociación de la caída del apartheid y
después tuvo una participación
fundamental dirigiendo la comisión para
la verdad y la reconciliación que fue la
herramienta creada por el gobierno de
mandela para
estudiar para conocer los crímenes que
se habían cometido durante la partida en
sudáfrica y propender por la
reconciliación nacional y explicaros
porque tutu cobra relevancia
internacional
a ver tú tú también tuvo una
participación internacional muy
importante se reúne en
eeuu en las naciones unidas en el reino
unido tuvo un montón de visitas durante
su vida a un montón de lugares antes y
después de la caída del apartado siempre
propendiendo por la solución pacífica de
control de conflictos durante la partida
y su objetivo fue justamente conseguir
el apoyo internacional para primero para
que se impusieran sanciones al régimen
del apartado en sudáfrica de hecho
seguro se reúne por ejemplo con wigan en
eeuu en washington y le dice que su
posición es demasiado complaciente con
el régimen de la parte dedicada
necesario que cambia la posición de eeuu
30 del gobierno y después de la calidad
del apartheid empieza a utilizar la
experiencia sudafricana para apoyar y
ayudar en la resolución de otros
conflictos
irlanda del norte estuvo en nicaragua
estuvo en liberia estuvo en el aire es
decir utiliza la experiencia sudafricana
para llegar a otros lugares entonces su
papel a nivel internacional es
fundamental como una las figuras en la
calidad régimen de la parte y desde el
púlpito este arzobispo emérito daba
discursos en contra del racismo pero
como la iglesia anglicana recibía de sus
discursos en contra de la minoría blanca
a ver a su llegada a hacer al ser obispo
de johannesburgo y arzobispo de de
ciudad del cabo tuvo bastantes problemas
acuérdate que las personas que lo
elegían eran blancas y también negras y
de hecho él fue el primer obispo negro
de johannesburgo y el primer arzobispo
negro de ciudad del cabo que llevó a que
incluso muchos miembros blancos de la
iglesia se salieran cuando fue nombrado
en
este papel de arzobispo sobre todo en
ciudad del cabo le permitió tener acceso
a la iglesia de san jorge en pleno
corazón de ciudad de cabo en pleno
corazón blanco de ciudad del cabo y le
permitió a él tener una posición muy
fuerte para liderar todas estas
protestas y estas marchas encontrarán la
parte ahí pudo tener una voz muy fuerte
sí gracias señor delgado y nosotros
seguimos con otras noticias porque este
domingo se cumple un mes desde que la
organización mundial de la salud declaró
la variante omicron de el coronavirus
como preocupante desde entonces esto se
ha extendido desde sudáfrica al resto
del mundo
hace un mes en la nueva variante del
coronavirus la de punto 1.1 529 fue
declarada como preocupante por la ms hoy
anunciamos al ave punto 1.1 529 como
variante preocupante bajo el nombre de
omicron detectada por primera vez en
sudáfrica y conocida como omicron su
alta transmisibilidad hizo saltar las
alarmas en los gobiernos a lo largo de
todo el mundo impulsando nuevos cierres
de fronteras y dejando en un principio
aislados a varios países del sur de
áfrica
la imposición de prohibiciones de viaje
a sudáfrica y a una serie de países del
sur de áfrica son lamentables injustas y
poco científicas teniendo en cuenta que
fueron nuestros propios científicos
científicos africanos los primeros en
detectar la variante omicron affliction
sanches países como reino unido francia
e italia alcanzaron el récord de
contagios en cuestión de semanas
impulsando restricciones como el retorno
del porte de mascarillas en exterior en
españa hasta un estricto confinamiento
en países bajos pero es la variante
micro tan peligrosa como se cree los
primeros análisis sugieren que los casos
de omicron tienen un 15% menos de
probabilidades de acudir al hospital y
40% menos de probabilidades de ser
hospitalizados durante una noche o más
omicron es la variante que más
mutaciones acumula en su genoma y por
tanto la más contagiosa y aunque sus
efectos fueran más leves su alta
transmisibilidad pone en riesgo de
colapso a los sistemas de salud produce
síntomas similares a los de un catarro
común poca pérdida del olfato y más
contagios entre recuperados o vacunados
ahora un mes después de su denominación
como preocupante las investigaciones
siguen pero en este panorama la buena
noticia es que sus efectos sobre el
mundo actual son mucho menores gracias a
la combinación de la vacunación las
defensas naturales por los contagios
previos de kobe 19 y la posible levedad
del virus los científicos sin embargo
siguen recomendando la prudencia
y más de 7000 vuelos fueron cancelados
en todo el mundo durante el fin de
semana de navidad por el pico de
contagios de covite 19 muchos por la
variante omicron varias compañías aéreas
que han comunicado que el linaje afectó
directamente a sus tripulaciones y
operadores esto ha generado la
cancelación y miles de retrasos aunque
hasta el momento no se conoce qué tan
grave puede llegar a ser la enfermedad
que produce la variante omicron está
confirmado que es la más transmisible
hasta el momento
israel quiere duplicar en cinco años su
población en los asentamientos ilegales
en los altos del golán esta es una zona
que los israelíes se anexaron
unilateralmente y sin el reconocimiento
internacional desde hace 40 años y siria
todavía reclama como propia esta zona
andrés granadillo tiene la historia
duplicar la población judía en los altos
del golán a pesar de que es un
territorio en disputa ese es el plan del
primer ministro israelí naftalí bennett
si todo lo mal primero hay que decir que
los altos del golán son israelíes esto
es evidente la ley israelí se ha
aplicado aquí desde 1981 y eso está más
allá de todo debate el hecho de que la
administración trump haya reconocido
esto y el hecho de que la administración
de bailén ha dejado en claro que no hubo
cambios en esta política es un asunto
importante hollywood
el gobierno israelí anunció el plan de
300 millones de dólares con los que
construirá 7 mil 300 viviendas en un
plazo de 5 años
ney y su fin estableceremos dos nuevas
comunidades en los altos del golán asif
y matar aumentaremos comunidades allí
states wood el territorio fue ocupado
por israel tras la guerra de los seis
días en 1967 en 1981 y trae el anexo
otros 1.200 kilómetros cuadrados una
medida rechazada por la comunidad
internacional siria exige la devolución
de esta meseta estratégica que también
limita con el líbano y jordania unos 20
mil rusos la mayoría de los cuales
todavía se identifican como sirios viven
en el área en 2019 la administración de
donald trump hizo que estados unidos
reconociera la soberanía de israel sobre
el territorio pero el resto de la
comunidad internacional no lo ha hecho
en febrero el actual secretario de
estado de eeuu anthony blinken dijo que
el control sobre el golán sigue siendo
de importancia real para la seguridad de
israel los estadounidenses denuncian la
presencia en siria de grupos de milicias
respaldados un aliado principal del jefe
del régimen sirio bashar al-assad más de
400 personas de diferentes
nacionalidades nadaron en el río moldava
con temperaturas entre los 3 y los 4
grados celsius este es un evento que se
repite cada año en praga la capital de
república checa la competencia navideña
se llama alfredo nikodem en un homenaje
al pionero de la natación de invierno él
fue el primero en desafiar las frías
aguas en 1923 y poco a poco más personas
se le sumaron hasta convertirse en una
tradición checa y así despedimos nuestra
emisión de noticias pero ustedes sigan
conectados a la señal de france 24
[Música]